[Music]
I avoid them at all costs I like to be
scared totally scared I don't personally
like horror movies I get freaked out I'm
scared of scary movies but I'm totally
addicted to them I do not want to spend
any of my time imagining somebody's
gonna kill me
I'm afraid of demons enough they're like
you know our team excites like life
imitates Paul I've been a fan of horror
movies since I was a little kid parts of
my brain that are held by certain scary
movies that I saw when I was younger
like I wish I could get those parts of
my brain back you grow up you learn
about the world and you know you put
some of the imagination to the side and
that's what I like about horror movies
is that what's your imagination come
flooding back in I can feel it jump
scare coming and I'll be like yeah I
just closed my eyes and then I'll look
to the side and see what someone's doing
and it that's kind of fun too because
you see someone's face but it's the
sound more than the what you see if I
have nightmares I know is good I don't
like to have nightmares but I like the
thrill of a monster because it's kind of
like going on a roller coaster it's
scary but it's also fun it's hard to be
scared when you get older I can't even
read scary scripts they know to not even
send them to me anymore I don't want to
be - dude - dad's a dumb death in the in
the horror that would you me in what in
what room everybody back up I'm going uh
I want to be traumatized when I go see a
scary movie
[Music]